I really like your outfit.
Thanks, I struggled.
It's been a long time since I've been in person
doing an interview, let alone with the amazing you.
So I didn't know what to wear.
And I ended up with this denim-on-denim ensemble,
the 1990s retro Chucks, which I at the time
thought were cool.
And this old flea market sweater.
I speak vintage.
And I would like that sweatshirt
when you're done with that.
It's yours.
Okay, that's good!
Well, you play a doctor on television
but your real life family are doctors.
Mm hmm.
I read a quote that you were saying
you feel like you're finally part of the family business
because you do this on the show now.
I'm finally respected at the dinner table now
and now I'm at least saving lives for pretend.
So I feel like it's a step up.
Do you have, you know, people on the set
who are like keeping it straight and real?
Yeah, oh yeah, yeah.
We've got, we've got doctors and nurses
who keep us honest and, you know
point out all of our horrific flaws and the ways
that we're mispronouncing every single medical term,
but we make it happen.
And it's been amazing to have them because, you know
when you're doing a show that incorporates the pandemic
and you're telling the story about that
it's amazing to talk to these frontline workers
about that experience and just the incredible amount
of work that it's been for them.
Okay, so knowing and really loving your show
and knowing that you are a musician and you love music,
and you said that you would love "New Amsterdam"
at one point, even if it's in your fantasy
to break into song.
What song is it?
Oh my God, that's impossible.
As you said that, for whatever reason,
"I Want To Break Free", Queen, just came to mind.
Perfect!
I don't know where that fits,
I dunno where it makes sense, but...
Because it's anthemic and also,
I think we all want to break out of something
right now and free sounds...
Yeah, yeah.
But do you see life in a musical?
I heard that you like walk around New York City
and either listen to Bach or hear Bach in your head.
I would say Dylan.
Dylan more than Bach.
Like I remember when I first moved to New York,
I was in a cab and I had "Fourth Time Around"
by Bob Dylan on, from "Blonde On Blonde".
And I just remember watching the whole city go by
and it was like moving there,
and now I'm here in New York and it was just like
that was a cool experience, that always stuck with me.
Well, you actually have a New York experience
story that I hearken to when I think of you,
which is I was hanging out with you and my car got towed
and we had to go to a Brooklyn tow yard.
Yeah.
And it was like, it felt like a musical.
It did.
It literally was a movie.
There were just no cameras.
Exactly.
It was perfect.
You of course, made friends with everybody
who worked there who were so excited that you were there.
It was freezing.
I wasn't dressed to be outside.
I was in like, something like this
but it was like, you know,
30 degrees
28.
Yes, exactly.
And we were starving.
I mean, we were just completely unprepared...
Yes! (laughs)
For this to happen.
I was underdressed, we didn't have any food.
It was late.
And we got pizza from a grocery store, from a very sweet,
do you remember her name?
'Cause I almost...
She was so sweet.
It was like Minnie.
And yes, and she gave me crap, it was great.
Yeah she did give you crap.
And then we just had a slice on the curb waiting
for your car, talking about,
you know, Woody Allen movies and stuff.
Yes.
And Albert Brooks and yeah.
Love of film and storytelling
and great things being put out there.
Yeah.
What do you want people to take away
from this new season of this very beloved show?
I know your network really loves it.
I know it really speaks to people.
Your family is in medicine.
The world is in a state
that we could have never guessed it would be.
What do you think that people can get
out of your show and what is the intention behind it?
It's not easy to do that dance
on a medical show right now in 2020 and 2021.
Right.
Yeah, you know, I think the show is best.
I always love when the show succeeds
in tackling a macro issue like racism or climate change
or homelessness or something that's sort
of seemingly unrelated to a hospital,
that's healthcare or what,
but certainly involves people's health
whether it's mental or physical and why people end up
in the hospital.
It tackles a macro issue like that on a very micro level,
on the individual level.
And it's about, for me at least my character's journey
is about acknowledging that, you know, one guy, one girl,
one person can't change the system overnight
by him or herself.
But you might be able to positively impact one person's life
or a few people or a community.
And that ripple effect is real, you know
and that creates change.
So that's, that's I think what the show does well.
Well, I'm really glad that I asked.
'Cause that was such a good answer.
I'm serious.
I'm so glad that you came, and like came in person.
Yes, it is so, so happy to be here live.
I've missed humanity and people
and conversations in real life.
So it's quite lovely.
Well, thank you for coming in the studio
and "New Amsterdam" airs Tuesdays at 10:00 PM on NBC.
(upbeat music)